das ist wirklich sensationell einem
hobby astronomen aus argentinien ist
jetzt das gelungen was sich suchroboter
und forschungsteams weltweit schon lange
erträumen das leitbild einer supernova
was einer lücke seines dachfensters hat
erstmalig eine supernova live auf fotos
festhalten können die ganze unglaubliche
geschichte jetzt ein klick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
erst vor kurzem haben wir von einem
funkamateur hier berichtet der
tatsächlich den totgeglaubten
nasa-satelliten image aufgespürt hat und
auch diese geschichte hier beweist mal
wieder dass amateure eine wichtige rolle
bei neuen wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen spielen können
jedenfalls konkret geht es um viktor
bout so aus argentinien im september
2016 hatte sich der hobby astronom eine
neue kamera für sein 40 zentimeter
teleskop geleistet in der nacht des 26
septembers dann passierte es er hatte
teile des daches nicht einmal richtig
aufgeschoben um seinen nachbarn nachts
nicht zu stören
doch auch wenn die bedingungen alles
andere als ideal waren er wollte auf
alle fälle seine neue kamera testen wo
so richtete sein teleskop auf die
galaxie ngc 610 sie ist seit dem 19
jahrhundert im sogenannten new channel
katalog aufnehmen oder ein cluster auf
stars eben ngc verzeichnet in dem alle
galaktischen sternhaufen galaxien usw
aufgelistet sind diese galaxie war für
buße zu diesem zeitpunkt wohl das
einfach sinn testobjekt denn sie befand
sich direkt senkrecht über ihn
somit hatte die lichtverschmutzung nur
wenig einfluss buß stellte die
belichtungszeit auf 20 sekunden ein
die erste bild reiterei die nach 20
minuten 40 bilder zum ergebnis hatte ja
die waren nicht sagen doch die
ergebnisse buß zweiter bildreihe sind
dagegen umso spektakulärer denn
plötzlich entwickelte sich eine
supernova in der frühen phase
die zu diesem zeitpunkt nur im
computermodellen existiert hat ihr name
sn 2010 gg obwohl die lichtbedingungen
alles andere als optimal waren lieferte
buß neue kamera brauchbare bilder denn
die supernova war sehr hell und dem
hobby astronom gelang es tatsächlich die
steigende helligkeit zu dokumentieren
und verwertbare daten zu liefern und das
obwohl supernovae eher selten sind
studien zufolge passieren sie in einer
durchschnittlichen galaxie mit etwa 100
milliarden sternen nur etwa alle 100
jahre bus beobachtung waren also ein
absoluter volltreffer vergleichbar mit
dem hauptgewinn beim lotto spielen die
wahrscheinlichkeit in einer einstündigen
beobachtung aller galaxien sie die erste
stunde des aufleuchten einer supernova
zu
zu bekommen liegt bei eins zu einer
million das ist also wirklich einmalig
denn bei früheren supernova entstehung
waren die forschungsteams immer ein
bisschen zu spät dran ist ja logisch
weil erst muss sie ja anfangen so
explodieren und dann kam er erst die
teleskope ausrichten zum beispiel auf
die supernova sn 2011 diese wurde zwar
durch kammern und röntgenblitze
beobachtet aber erst später band eben im
sichtbaren licht bei der supernova case
and 2011
war man früher dran doch auch hier
verpasste man die ankunft der
schockwelle an der sternoberfläche wenn
erst einmal die supernova bekannt wird
geht die suche erst richtig los wanted
der stern der explodiert war nicht
wirklich einfach beim millionen
lichtjahren entfernung
denn die ist so hell die supernova dass
man gar nicht exakt wissen kann wo ist
jetzt der stern sowie verschiedene daten
der supernova wie beispielsweise der
helligkeit und der aufgezeichneten
lichtspektrum kann dann analysiert
werden welche sterne in frage kommen
viktor bout so ist jetzt jedenfalls
achtung co autor in einer der
renommiertesten wissenschaftlichen
fachzeitschriften der welt nature tempo
so meldete seine entdeckung ganz schnell
an die international astronomical junien
und an weitere wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nach vielen
untersuchungen gehen die beteiligten
forschungsteams davon aus dass es sich
um einen doppelstern handeln muss 19,5
sonnenmassen hatte wohl der explodierte
stern
sein begleiter 13,5 sonnenmassen ein
anderes modell kommt zu dem ergebnis
dass der stern a15 und dass der stern b
als 25 sonnenmassen gehabt haben muss
welches modell der wahrheit am nächsten
kommt das wird man spätestens dann sehen
wenn der zweite stern die verblassende
supernova dann später überstrahlt davon
sind dann die forschungsteams überzeugt
der zweite stern sollte weit genug
entfernt gewesen sein um die supernova
zu überstehen
fest steht auch dass basars bilder und
datensätze die theoretischen prognosen
weitestgehend bestätigen bei der ankunft
der schockwelle an der sternoberfläche
stieg die helligkeit zwar etwas
langsamer als vorausgesagt an
doch der grund dafür liegt
wahrscheinlich darin dass der stern im
vorfeld schon große massen abgestoßen
hatte
so wurde ein teil des lichts blockiert
oder und da darf man auch dass davon
auch nicht ausschließen dass diese
erstmalige live beobachtung einer
supernova wieder zu neuen ärger
wissen über supernovae führt wir dürfen
auf jeden fall gespannt sein und zwar
sehr gespannt wenn ihr als erstes neues
zum thema supernovae und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video das melde ich euch
dort eben vorab und das garantiert ihr
könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von
krieg zum mitmachen und mit themen
vorschlagen oder mit abstimmung
mitbestimmen was sie auf dem kanal
passiert einfach hier draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das aber mit der glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter also hier
dafür drauf klicken da geht es um eine
zombie supernova auch sehr spannend denn
sonst würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran
[Musik]